pour en parler nous sommes avec un
claude rambaud vice-président de france
aso santé bonsoir claude rambaud merci
d'avoir en direct sur arte france quand
vous entendez ces mesures notamment à
l'étranger israël qui qui ferme ses
frontières pendant deux semaines au pays
européens dont la france l'italie qui
ferme ses écoles ses crèches jusqu'au 15
mars vous trouvez que c'est sur leur
réagiront c'est une manne chez pas la
mesure de précaution et israël je
comprends je ne sais pas du tout
pourquoi ils ferment leurs portes je
crois que c'est par rapport à où qatar
si j'ai bien compris aussi des pays
proches
enfin dans les pays européens les pays
où seraient par exemple n'a pas le droit
d'aller en israël pendant oui bon c'est
un choix politique qui est fait je
comprends mieux l'italie la fermeture
des écoles de même que morrison saunière
annoncé que s'il se déclarait en
épidémie il prépare la déclaration
épidémie il faudrait une loi pour aussi
fermer toutes les écoles parce que la
fermeture des écoles si vous voulez
c'est la distanciation avec les enfants
c'est social social exemple parce que
les enfants sont des véritables vecteurs
dans cette maladie l'a en partie déjà
une leçon pour la grippe à ce qui ne se
lave pas les mains par exemple ou bien à
l'école ils peuvent pas vraiment ça y
est les mamans on le sait donc il ramène
ça entre eux et le ramène à la maison
mais surtout danse dans le cas présent
de cette maladie de cofidis n'a autant
d'excusés moi je vous arrête parce que
ça intéresse beaucoup moins forcément
vous poursuivrez votre idée est
évidemment dans quelques instants mais
enfin vous dites est des vecteurs de
maladies ça veut dire que éventuellement
les enfants aujourd'hui peuvent être
plus porteurs 6 1 c'est ça voulait sans
le savoir ou de symptômes voilà et et
les ramener à leurs parents et voilà
lorsqu'elle se voit saisonnalité
symptômes ils ont très peu de symptômes
donc si vous voulez si vous si vous
voulez si vous fermez les écoles les
enfants se rencontrent plus comme ne se
lève pas les mages revient à ça il ne se
partagent plus les virus dont qu'ils ont
très peu de symptômes donc ça permet si
vous voulez de lycées l'épidémie au lieu
d'avoir un pic on va lisser c'est un
choix politique qui fait parce que in
fine et y aura sans doute le même nom
mais auto v d'avoir des afflux de
patients à l'hôpital
ça va engager les hôpitaux d'un seul
coup si on a un pic très pointus ou bien
aussi au lieu d'avoir trop
pour pas oublier que halak est pendant
la canicule on a vu ce que ça pouvait
donner si on est 20 engorgement des des
pompes funèbres par exemple donc ça va
lisser ça va permettre aussi de se
préparer et ça va amortir les choses
donc quand même une bonne chose une
bonne mesure qu'il faudrait alors c'est
un choix qui est fait pas ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre choix
c'est vrai que ça déportés économique de
fermer les écoles donc c'est un choix
vous disiez les enfants qui ne savent
pas toujours les mains en quoi est ce si
important
alors que la ville est très important de
se laver les mains parce qu'on se
portent les mains à la bouche
en fait c'est pas parce que le virus est
dans les mains qui va traverser la peau
c'est pas ça du tout mais on se porte
en général les mains au visage et à la
bouche très souvent hier j'étais dans
une réunion au ministère de la santé
humaine et j'arrêtais pas de voir des
messieurs qui se caresser la barbe qui
se voit là et les dames aussi se mettent
les mares au visage mais les enfants se
sucent beaucoup les mains et se sucent
bras et les doigts
donc ils s'infecte abcès puisque c'est
un c'est un virus qui va sur le système
respiratoire
mais on en trouve beaucoup dans ce qu'on
appelle le tractus digestif c'est à dire
tout le tube digestif de du haut en bas
donc voilà c'est pour éviter de se
porter des mains sales
au niveau du visage alors on a des
nouveaux chiffres ce soir 285 cas en
france 15 personnes actuellement
réanimation quatre décès ça vous évoque
quoi ces chiffres est ce que vous faites
partie de ces personnes qui pensent
qu'il faut arrêter cette psychose qu'on
en fait peut-être un peu trop où je mens
s'il n'ya pas lieu d'avoir une psychose
je pense que c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut prendre très au sérieux
il n'ya pas lieu d'avoir une psychose il
faut donner une bonne information à la
population
il faut faire une bonne prévention il
faut prendre des mesures on entend aussi
le fait qu' on réplique solution
hydroalcoolique
on peut déjà se laver les mains mais on
peut aussi faire baiser des solutions
hydro-alcooliques soi même ça coûte pas
cher et à louer mais cela mis en place
une formule qui permet d'en faire soi
même c'est pas très difficile de même
que des masques si on veut on peut aussi
en faire soi même il ya des tutos qui
circulent qui sont excellents on peut
aussi si on éprouve le besoin d'avoir un
masque la question du masque elle est
surtout pour les patients
qu'ils sont infectés et cela en mourant
il prend en bénéficier pour protéger
leur entourage
mais si certaines personnes éprouvent le
besoin de faire des masses qui peuvent
en faire ça a quand même un intérêt même
si c'est beaucoup moins efficace que le
masque on met au la personne malade ça à
l'intéressé que ça prévient du geste de
porter la main au visage comme on a mal
on va moins se toucher près de la bouche
alors vous dites voilà pas de psychose
nécessaire c'est pas souhaitable il faut
juste d'avoir de l'information
le souci qui se rencontrent souvent
c'est que l'information elle n'est pas
toujours évidente parce qu'on le connaît
mal ce virus toujours aussi mal voilà on
voit des personnes malades on se livre à
zut alors ils sont là à côté de nous en
entreprise
comment on pallie justement à ce type de
difficultés il ya peu de gens qui savent
finalement vraiment ce qu'il faut faire
ce qu'il faut c'est se tenir
quand on le peut dans les transports en
commun c'est très difficile c'est
pourtant là que avoir un masque dans les
transports en commun ça évite de toucher
les rampes les bars pour lui de se
mettre les mains envisage donc c'est pas
c'est pas si inutile que ça on peut
aussi mettre des gants des transports en
commun maintenant dans les entreprises
on n'est pas obligé d'être en
promiscuité
on peut s'organiser pour être un maître
et on sait que l'on est les protéger
mais comme nous par exemple
winona de la shoah effectivement on est
loin
alors on est toujours au stade de
anodisé la porte parole du gouvernement
qui voit là on sent n'excluent pas un
passage prochain anstett 3 ça voudra
dire quoi pour fêter le passage en stade
3 ça voudra dire que le virus circule
vraiment vraiment et qu'ils aient besoin
il aura besoin à ce moment là de prendre
des mesures comme le sel qui sont prises
actuellement en italie par exemple la
fermeture des écoles éventuellement de
l'arrêt d'un certain nombre de
manifestations notamment sportives
ça c'est déjà des choses auxquelles on
pense mais aussi des mesures diverses
pour les entreprises pour l'aide aux
entreprises ça débloque la situation
autrement
mais salah bloque un peu économiquement
évidemment il faut tout simplement on
appelé au bon sens et à la
responsabilité de chacun dans ce type
intelligent
oui c'est sûr bien sûr ne serait ce
qu'en dit que c'est bon il vaut il faut
éviter
il ne faut pas se terrer plutôt se
serrer la main parce que toujours les
mêmes raisons c'est que la main que l'on
vous temps vous ne savez pas du tout
quelles mains elle a touché avant et si
elle est porteuse du virus est ensuite
si vous allez le temps de vous nettoyer
les mains entre 2 c'est pas voilà de
même qu'il faut pas s'embrasser certain
nombre de mesures comme ça qui sont déjà
donnés par le ministre lui-même
d'ailleurs l'om est apporté de nouveau
chief taux de mortalité globale liée aux
quotas virus et selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé de 3,4 pour cent le
précédent chiffre était de 2,3 pour cent
ça aussi mais il a dit quoi qu'on ait
passé et ce qui est incompréhensible
c'est qu'on n'a pas les mêmes chiffres
partout on va dire c'est entre 1 et 3%
alors pas ce qui est pas mal et il est
vrai que très certainement comme ce
n'est pas quand même à une mortalité
très élevée on est très loin de ce qui
s'est passé avec le strass par exemple
mais c'est plus que la grippe n'est en
moi et très certainement si on avait un
comptage beaucoup plus précis des
personnes contaminées
là le chiffre abaisserait or on ne
compte que les personnes qui sont très
sérieusement malade près certainement
enfin concernant le profil des personnes
décédées on en parle évidemment souvent
c'est communément admis maintenant de
dire qu'il s'agit des personnes âgées ou
des personnes à risque mais mais
concrètement est ce qu'on sait de
manière certaine quelles sont les
personnes à risque qui ont telle
pathologie alors à mon lycée sont c'est
d'abord les personnes âgées parce
qu'elles ont des défenses plus on avance
en âge plus les défenses affaiblissent
mais on le sait pour les maladies
chroniques
surtout les personnes qui ont des
problèmes déjà respiratoires les branco
pneus pour mettre nos maux pâtit
chronique obstructive chronique on sait
qu'ils sont ils le savent ces personnes
là sont déjà prévenu qu'il faut vraiment
qu'ils se protègent les personnes qui
ont des influences rénale aussi
évidemment parce qu'on a un syndrome de
défaillance fait souvent généralisée et
qui très tôt vont amener les gens en
réanimation donc c'est défaillance
multiviscérale c'est plusieurs viscères
qui m'ont qui ont dysfonctionné et
scellant cet ensemble qui fait que
on va avoir une issue à cette fatale il
ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes parfois chez
des parents qui ont des enfants
asthmatiques ils sont nombreux dans les
grandes villes on dit que les enfants
risquent pas grand chose mais enfin les
kids d alors va-t-il les enfants peuvent
être contaminés oui ils peuvent même
être malade on le sait qu'il ya eu c'est
le taux est très très bas et voilà mais
on n'a pas de décès parmi les enfants
pour le moment elle n'a pas relevé au
niveau mondial pourvu que ça dure en
toile cas merci merci aux médias ni
l'odeur rambo d'avoir été avec nous
vice-présidente de france à sos santé
mercier m